an overnight shooting turns a typical
saturday night at the bar
deadly thank you so much for joining us
at five o'clock
i'm sasha loftis this happened at a pt's
place near charleston and decatur
police are now searching for the suspect
involved kate houston joins us live in
the newsroom tonight
after speaking with people in the area
kate yes sasha police are still trying
to figure out what exactly
led up to this shooting many people i
spoke to say it's usually a quiet area
and we're shocked to hear that this
happened police say the two people
involved were both
at the pt's for hours before the
shooting happened
and didn't interact a little after 3 a.m
the suspect walked over
shot a man in his late 20's and left
police say this happened in the
westland complex which has many major
retailers and businesses
shoppers that i spoke to say they've
been going here for years without any
problems
so this comes as a surprise it's
absolutely concerning
and it is a fluke to me because it
you don't hear about stuff like that
around here as much you know it's not
this side of town kind of shocking and
kind of scary because i'm like
okay because especially if it was random
like that means anybody
anywhere can just randomly hey you never
know
right now police are going through
surveillance video from pt's place
we have requested that video from pt's
and police but have not yet heard back
at this time there is no description of
the suspect police are asking anyone
with information to contact them
or crime stoppers back to you sasha